[Música]
la asamblea nacional de Venezuela
elegida en 2015 votó para eliminar la
figura del gobierno interino que es
liderado por Juan guaidó bajo el
argumento de ser una estrategia política
fallida guaidó afirmó que esta medida
beneficiará al gobierno de Nicolás
maduro
en Estados Unidos tras una demanda del
Gobierno Federal por invadir terrenos
del gobierno y también dañar el medio
ambiente las autoridades de Arizona se
vieron obligadas a eliminar el muro de
contenedores instalado en la Jam
militarizada y también concurrida
frontera con México
y el senado de Estados Unidos aprobó una
ayuda de 45 mil millones de dólares para
Ucrania una suma que Integra también el
gasto de 1,7 billones de dólares
aprobado para el aumento en el gasto
militar que contempla también misiles
Patriot y Mars y equipos de logística
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a esta
nueva este nuevo bloque informativo aquí
en France 24 soy Santiago López González
vamos a comenzar en América Latina en
Venezuela los exdiputados de la asamblea
nacional elegida en 2015 votaron a favor
de eliminar la figura del gobierno
interino que lidera el opositor Juan
guaidó en una primera sesión los ex
diputados votaron 72 votos a favor de la
eliminación y 23 en contra lo que deja
entonces en la cuerda floja la
permanencia de Juan guaidó como el
rostro de la oposición política contra
el gobierno de Nicolás maduro un segundo
debate tendrá lugar el 29 de diciembre y
Será esa la fecha cuando el legislativo
tome una decisión definitiva
Cuáles herramientas tenemos hoy para
enfrentar a esta dictadura la unidad la
primera reforzado hoy con la plataforma
unitaria y la convocatoria primaria
también el acuerdo de gobernabilidad
parlamental que debe respetar este
parlamento nacional para conservar el
poder legítimo que de nuevo y como le
decía Hace unos días se lo digo a
Venezuela se instala el cinco de enero
las pretensiones también de la dictadura
de querer acabar con el parlamento
electo y Mientras tanto en Chile el
presidente Gabriel borich anunció que su
país abrirá una embajada en Palestina
decisión que no ha escapado de la
controversia en ese país chile al igual
que otros países alrededor del mundo
tienen una representación ante la
autoridad Palestina Pero esta decisión
convierte a Chile en el primer estado
del mundo en contar con una
representación diplomática oficial en
territorio palestino y no es una
coincidencia chile alberga la mayor
comunidad de ciudadanos palestinos fuera
de medio oriente también reconoció a
este territorio como un estado y los
respaldó para su ingreso en la UNESCO
vamos a Elevar el carácter de nuestra
representación oficial en Palestina de
encargado de negocios que hoy día vamos
a abrir una embajada durante nuestro
gobierno para darle
la representación que corresponde y
exigir exigir en todos los espacios algo
tan básico algo tan básico tan simple
pero que hoy día nos está haciendo que
es que se respete el derecho
internacional ni nada más ni nada menos
Vamos hasta Estados Unidos las
autoridades del estado de Arizona
acordaron eliminar el gigantesco muro de
contenedores que está instalado en la
frontera con México algunos expertos han
señalado que pone en peligro numerosas
especies locales Valentina Torres nos
cuenta más
son más de 900 los contenedores que
fueron ubicados en el bosque nacional
Coronado en la frontera sur del estado
de Arizona y ahora tendrán que ser
removidos el gobernador republicano
dogsy aceptó retirarlos tras la demanda
Federal presentada a principios de
diciembre el muro fue diseñado para
disuadir el paso de migrantes
irregulares calificado de siniestro por
el gobernador pero la demanda indica que
los contenedores fueron ubicados de
forma ilegal en terrenos federales y
ponen en peligro la vida Silvestre
es el lugar de una increíble diversidad
de vida Silvestre una de las áreas de
conservación más importantes de todo
Estados Unidos
es una parte de la frontera muy difícil
de cruzar para los migrantes y hasta
donde sabemos no hay mucha actividad
migratoria
el plazo para remover los contenedores
se cumple el próximo cuatro de enero dos
días después de que la demócrata Katy
hobbes asuma como gobernadora
la situación se presenta justamente
cuando crece el temor por la llegada de
miles de migrantes a ciudades del Norte
de México mientras esperan que expire el
llamado título 42 que permitía la
expulsión Exprés por motivos sanitarios
la nueva oleada ha hecho que las
autoridades de México y Estados Unidos
aumenten la presencia militar pero los
migrantes no están dispuestos a
retirarse estamos en Navidad muchos
están compartiendo con su familia uno se
tuvo que venir fuera de su familia
y sus hijos pasando necesidad Pues hay
un 24 de diciembre que tú no sabes dónde
van a dormir en principio quedaba
derogada el 21 de diciembre pero la
Corte Suprema lo aplazó hasta el día 27
la normativa ha permitido expulsar a más
de un millón de migrantes y su
eliminación significa una luz de
esperanza en su búsqueda por una nueva
vida
seguimos hablando de Estados Unidos
porque este país vivirá su Navidad más
fría desde 1980 así lo indicó el
servicio meteorológico al anunciar que
la mayoría de los estados se van a ver
afectados por una tormenta invernal que
ya está provocando un fuerte descenso en
las temperaturas cerca de 2000 vuelos ya
fueron cancelados Andrés triviño tiene
los detalles
Estados Unidos vivirá una vida más fría
en cuatro décadas casi todos los estados
del país sienten los estragos de la gran
tormenta invernal Elliot la cual deja
más de 90 millones de personas en alerta
máxima principalmente en el medio oeste
y la región de los grandes lagos por lo
que las autoridades han estado a sus
ciudadanos a tomarse en serio la
tormenta
no es un día de nieve normal como cuando
eran niños en serio y mi equipo está
listo para ayudar a las comunidades a
sobrellevar esta tormenta
se espera que Durante los próximos días
Elliot se convierta en una bomba
ciclónica con ráfagas de viento tan
fuertes que pueden alcanzar el
equivalente a un huracán categoría 3
provocando hasta 30 centímetros de nieve
y temperaturas entre los 10 y los 20
grados bajo cero este jueves Más de
2.200 vuelos fueron cancelados y se
espera que la situación empeore tanto en
las vías como en los aeropuertos siendo
una de las festividades en las que los
estadounidenses más se movilizan debido
a que tenemos que más despacio tenemos
que establecer programar o reducir
nuestro horario
ha sido un poco loco llegué temprano
para asegurarme de tomar mi vuelo y a la
puerta de embarque cuando me enteré que
Fue cancelado las aerolíneas
estadounidenses anunciaron que trabajan
para que Los viajeros puedan reunirse en
Navidad y eliminarán las tarifas de
cambio a Los afectados por la tormenta
entre el paquete militar de ayuda que
Estados Unidos enviará a Ucrania se
contempla también una batería de misiles
patred armas y también elementos de
logística desde el kremlin el presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin desestimó el
potencial de este sistema de defensa y
también criticó la ayuda proporcionada a
Ucrania
el viaje de bolodinskia Washington se
saldó con un millonario paquete de ayuda
militar para Ucrania y no hay duda de
Cuál es la pieza central
[Aplausos]
de casi 2 mil millones de dólares y el
elemento más fuerte de este paquete es
el sistema patreon reforzará
significativamente nuestra defensa aérea
es un paso importante en la creación de
un escudo aéreo eficaz para Ucrania
el sistema de misiles tierra aire ha
sido fabricado desde 1976 por el grupo
armamentístico estadounidense saltó a la
fama durante la Guerra del Golfo de 1991
y ha sido un equipo básico para el
ejército estadounidense y muchos de sus
aliados Ucrania recibirá una batería
contiene 4 misiles pack 2 como un
alcance de 160 kilómetros o 16 misiles
pack 3 con un alcance de 40 kilómetros
kiev para que la adquisición del sistema
Patriot cambie las reglas del juego en
la guerra con Rusia permitiéndole
rastrear y derribar mejor los misiles
balísticos pero una sola batería tendrá
un efecto limitado
los sistemas que ya tienen los nazam los
anti los Iris no pueden funcionar
realmente bien para eso están los
Patriots y francamente si el objetivo es
el VIP ni Pro o harkief un sistema
desplegado alrededor de kiev no va a
alcanzar esos objetivos no van a acertar
esos misiles necesitarán muchos más
Patriots
hasta que Ucrania no aumente su
capacidad con los patreon es poco
probable que los nuevos misiles tengan
un efecto decisivo en la guerra pero sí
una mayor capacidad para repeler los
ataques cierto alivio para la población
de kiev que sufre frecuentes bombardeos
vamos a cambiar de tema nos vamos hasta
Grecia en donde integrantes del cuerpo
de bomberos de Atenas la capital de ese
país se vistieron de Papá Noel Para
repartir regalos a menores de edad que
están enfermos en hospitales locales
haciendo uso de sus camiones de bomberos
de las grúas este grupo de bomberos
entregaron presentes a los pacientes del
hospital cancerológico águila Sofía de
la capital griega mientras que otros
descendieron en rapel por el costado del
hospital para entregar los regalos a
través de las ventanas a los menores que
por su condición médica no podían salir
al exterior
con estas imágenes finalizamos esta
Informativo en France 24 sigan con
nosotros
[Música]